I'll take five suggestions take one from
each quarter and then a wild card so
we'll come to come to this quarter first
what you guys dad jeans straight up you
can't prepare with that dad jeans dad
jeans is that a thing I know mom jeans
are no you're just trying to screw with
me I appreciate that
dad jeans back for to hear what you guys
suggestion guacamole
I mean it's technically a food but it's
I mean I guess it's a foreign food so
and this is more exciting than someone
who just goes cheese I'll take Walker
moly guacamole dad jeans back quadrant
over that oil leak yes yes my kind of
person everyone else like now we don't
like that suggestion but I'm taking oil
leak oil leak this side here tech
support
wait if this two people said that at the
same time do you know each other
no yeah you shut up liars you got a
little tech support headsets just go and
say tech support at the same time you'll
have to take it tech support
what particular type of tech support
software or how specific software tech
support or your leak dab jeans guacamole
let's take one final one this could be
this could be anything tool so someone
said flowers and someone said sexy moves
is that right yeah I'm gonna combine
that sexy moves using flowers that'll be
that and this then lovely people it's
not just a survey and I'm just gonna put
the microphone back in and leave this is
it's gonna be a little thing called a
freestyle rap that is a rap made up
entirely on the spot based entirely on
those suggestions suggestions being
wocka molise sexy moves and flowers dad
jeans oil leak and tech support with
software and do not worry it will not be
anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly toe-curling ly bad as you
are expecting a 29 year old privately
educated middle class white boy to be
some of you seem unconvinced this man
here laughed like this
you evil mofo if we can drop that Pete
good sir
less less somehow we do I'm excited even
if only about seven of you are yeah
that's what we like a little holler of
appreciation and applause it's gonna be
good it's gonna be good
good Christ good lord holy moly I'm at
the party he ignore the guacamole I'm
over here never worry about calories off
my hips and just a whole bag of chips
not potato why can't the ones I was not
born yesterday I get the Naturals filled
with corn
I dip them in oh yes I'm the best bro I
add extra hot sauce and avocado never
cilantro we call it coriander and don't
like each other Jean people don't
understand but in my mouth it tastes
like soap if it's in the guacamole
there's no hope I'm eating it yes I'm
feeling so keen to one day fit into a
pair of dad jeans
imagine that they're like bombs that I
surmise the mom jeans they're the ones
you wear quite high fashionable bring it
back from the 80s broke they're a style
of jeans we call retro and the dad wants
a must rip up and say they're better
than skinny jeans or Buca they're
earthen flares or carrot shape getting
me rapping about denim was the mistake I
bloody love denim I spit with these I
can buy jeans abroad again the denim
Japanese not these though they have a
prom bein fish they cost me $25 I'm a
basting fish I'm wearing
let me come over here I was not
surprised that you've got to at the same
time simultaneously you're like tech
support say it with me will shout it if
so he's aware that we're back mofos
working in software if you've got a
problem if you can't play ball we will
come round give it a nice fresh install
yeah get it off the disc drive takes a
boy help keep your computers alive and
do other things might not get laid
you're good to your jobs or you get paid
don't get laid up with your reports and
so I'm gonna hold it close and say I
really hope that as we speak we're not
about to go sky high with an oil leak
it's more viscous to think of than gas
kind of like a liquid have in the back
like I'm a Russian oligarch with the oil
on my tab pull me mr. Vidal north I take
it back I know no Russian surnames that
just made wonder oil in the ground the
machines this up they suck it up
it's just dinosaur blood I didn't do
science so I'm not that good and knowing
where oils come from so I drone on I
know it's essential that your form of
carbon that's been turned over the years
while we better move on to some nice
floors
that's French for flowers you should
have spent hours to learn the language I
like to hide them in my bum with the
sandwich that's the sexy booth that I
will show I'd get my shoe licks in my
two lips and blow
your holes in nose you've never seen a
sexy move and it smells like a rose by
any other name the smells are sweet I've
gotten rhododendrons between all my feet
I'm showing it
unlike maintenance of re-remember the
address in American PRT she's the one
gear test in the Mel was naked apart
from a few rose petals for me there was
no mistake in that's the sexiest flower
of a sexual awakening I was loving that
I won't disgrace me it's a shame I can't
watch that film now for some Kevin
Spacey there you go
you gotta be delightful my name's
Christina thank you very much and
goodbye
[Applause]